doing doing first and not uh over
complicating it with uh
with all kinds of considerations and
concerns right really taking action even
if that if you know that this action
isn't perfect or you don't have
everything you need at once you know
that you'll have a second chance and a
third chance and a fourth chance
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel welcome to
another episode of 20 minute leaders
another co-founder of a unicorn is
joining us meet nimrod vox co-founder
and head of product at big id
he has experienced an enterprise product
and a security executive and served in
various capacities ranging from
engineering product and business
management prior to founding big id
nimrod served as vp product management
product line manager for ca identity
management product line and as an
advisor to security startups in the area
of identity management and user behavior
analytics nimrod vox co-founder and head
of product of big id how are you today
good morning i'm good thank you how are
you
thank you for joining me um
six years ago seven years ago co-founded
big id
and one of the one of the most
impressive companies in the israel
ecosystem i believe he raised around 250
million dollars
unless i'm not updated anymore
but tackling the question of customer
privacy and customer data
and
and looking at regulations in the
growing market
obviously this is something that that is
new that the world has not had to
experience you know even 10 or 15 years
ago especially not to this extent so so
we're talking about a really emerging
market with a growing need and and
there's a lot for us to talk about but
what i'd love to do before we get to big
id tell me a little bit about yourself
and how you get to co-found big id about
six or seven years ago so first of all
it was like five years ago it sounded it
seems uh like a longer time but it's
really been about five years
um
so it all the kind of uh started that i
was at the time living in boston i was
uh head of product or some vp products
for ca's identity management product
line
um so dealing with the
provisioning of user accounts user
access management who has access to what
um single sign on those were kind of the
products that i was responsible for
um i came i started very early very
sorry very late in the itec market only
when i was kind of in my 30s um and um
and so i i wasn't really uh feeling like
that i was ready to start a company but
uh after a couple of years at ca
it was really uh
becoming apparent that uh
you know i could uh i could get be very
successful uh starting something on my
own and and so uh kind of uh in around
2014 i left ca prior to leaving cia i
met my co-founder dmitry who just sold
his last company to ca
uh
what what was
you know what was your conviction at
that moment where
which led you to feel okay maybe i can
actually go about an interesting route
myself what was it about you know your
day-to-day that gave you this impression
well you know uh so i was uh at ca ca
was a very big company and i've learned
learned a lot at ca got exposed to large
markets to large customers um
international markets uh flew to japan
and flew to to europe a lot
and and apj korea singapore
and one of the things that um we were
able to do at the ca me and kind of my
my friends from from the business unit
was to uh go out and define a new market
uh so we actually took a very old
product called the host access control
um which was uh kind of
very unix-centric very old and uh
pivoted towards them a newer market
called privileged identity management so
starting to compete with what were then
very successful startups like cyberark
and um
and doing it quite successfully and
after doing that we said no
oh [__] i mean why am i doing it for
such a large company i should have done
it for myself
and so when i started thinking and
looking around and it kind of
made the decision that i really want to
to start something on my own
um
and uh and kind of that was kind of the
deciding moment and after a few years
that uh
um in boston i kind of met a lot of uh
people and a lot of friends that had
startups in the area that more involved
in the startups local startup scene
um met a few investors here and there
and so i felt like uh you know it's
really up to me to
make that move and and succeed
um
and so as you are
thinking about making this move
you know go back maybe to to to that
moment
what did you feel like you had to do to
make that jump because leaving a large
company where you're what i'm hearing
you say you're very successful and
you're advancing and you're you're
feeling you know you're in a rate of
success so
it's pretty scary to just jump the boat
and start something of your own
yeah well obviously it was very exciting
at the ca but uh that the last year at
c8 you know started becoming more
difficult and you've kind of kind of
feel the the barriers of these large
companies very frustrated with being
able to uh
to deliver new um innovative software
and it's really not about the uh
engineering side or the uh
um or or the development side uh it's
it's the end-to-end um
ability to support uh new products uh in
sales in support uh the customers are
expecting much more mature solutions
from a company like uh like that um so
it's uh so
apart from being very frustrating it
kind of felt more
um
like there is a real opportunity and uh
those big companies can't really compete
with small startups
and so these two things kind of on one
hand the frustration i felt internally
and on the other hand you know i saw all
of those successful companies and the
opportunity out there and people you
know getting funded uh it kind of uh was
kind of the the the tipping point for me
and so i'm gonna already jump to to the
other to the other end so today uh big
idea i believe has uh just over 350
employees just according to to what i
found on linkedin
what what are you taking with you from
your previous experiences
that you're saying now that you're
growing a large company this is not this
is not a startup this is now a you know
one of the bigger companies in the
israeli ecosystem
what are you taking from those
experiences into the culture of big id
to foster this sense of innovation and
moving-ness so that other people in your
position back then wouldn't go and say
okay maybe we'll just go start something
of our own
look first of all it's still very much a
startup so
we're still very much about uh
getting and getting out there with new
products and new capabilities and kind
of competing and defining a new market
that is not really well defined yet so
it's very much a startup investing a lot
more in in in
building that market building products
building a sales force so a lot of
investment still flows into the into the
company all the time
so it's very much a startup
kind of
environment
what i took away from er
from my years at the in corporate
america of course is the understanding
of big customers and their needs
and understanding
how you know what needs what you need to
be successful so on one hand it's a very
very laser focus on what the customers
need and understanding um their their
their
problems and how they need to solve
those problems because these big
organizations have their own limitations
and have their own dynamics and you need
to factor that into the product um
and and how an enterprise sales team is
compensating how it works all of these
are learnings that i couldn't have
gotten anywhere else other than in a
company like that on the other hand i
know you know
about a couple of other things that you
have to get right for example you have
to get the product deployed you cannot
wait and just sell and be happy with it
you need the product to be immediately
deployed and the customer is using it
and and valuing it
and getting value out of it
which is super super important so that's
kind of the number one uh
kind of lesson
that i take
from this this this large kind of
enterprise market and the other thing is
how to watch out for uh small
competitors right because there's always
kind of a creeping up from beneath of
companies uh and even as a startup there
are always these um early stage
companies that just got funded
that have some kind of a promise um
that are looking at what you've done and
are looking at what's um
what you've uh haven't focused on and
started start focus on that
and so there's always a constant need to
be alert and be uh and understand what
your competitors
are doing and so that
you don't uh you don't stay behind right
a hundred percent okay see so what
you're addressing and over 200 billion
dollar market a growing market and you
know i think one of the things that
you're alluding to also is that we're
seeing a proliferation of companies that
are dealing with with similar issues
because these are really cool issues
that are only really relevant uh since
uh customers have been doing data-driven
customer journey approaches in this in
the last 10 years or so or 15 years
maximum so tell me a little bit about
the space that you're in and and then
how big id is is placed within this
ecosystem yeah sure so so like you said
right over the past 10 15 years uh
companies have been building their
business on data they have been
collecting unlimited amounts of data
they were using big data technologies to
basically reduce any limitation on the
amount of data they can collect and
process
um and as a result uh companies have not
been doing any deleting of data they
have only been
collecting and collecting
um and it reached a point where no
single person in the organization
especially in large organizations but
also in smaller organizations
know exactly what data you have
each business unit is collecting its own
data you'll have a flurry of different
marketing and data analytics um
tools in the organization even in the
organization as big as big id we're
already seeing different
groups and different people collecting
and using data
so so a large amount of data
organizations as a whole
don't really know their data
and what happened over the past five or
ten years
is that
there were a lot of breaches
uh there are a lot of uh scandals around
uh using of the data and uh and kind of
it became a more of a public
issue
um and and uh consumers are becoming
more aware of the need for privacy and
the implications of lack of privacy and
as a result uh legislation for privacy
uh became
uh kind of abundant right and it started
with the european gdpr and then uh the
the california consumer privacy act and
you have legislation in brazil and in
the uk and in australia and
india and japan so all around the world
you see legislations that are now uh
almost like accounting for finances are
requiring accounting for
data
and the organizations simply were not
prepared uh they did not have any um
kind of
global visibility into their data and
this is really the gap that big id came
to fill to give
organizations visibility to their data
to help them know their data connect to
all of their data sources catalog all
the data that they have classify the
data so they know what type of data they
have correlate that data back to their
consumers or their employees or their
business parties or
whatever they manage
as a business entity
and then give them visibility into that
the ability to take action on top of
that data with applications with an open
api that they can now
take action
uh on the data that they have whether
it's for better protection of the data
uh whether it's to get more value out of
the data or whether it's in order to
comply with the privacy regulations and
be able to address those needs and and
build trust with their with their
customers
right that was really the big
challenge
companies are you know they're very
horizontal you have a lot of different
functions that are collecting different
data from the marketing to the
engineering to the to to the different
data science teams that are that are
looking at data in different ways and so
where is big how does big idea actually
get into the pipeline of the enterprise
and who are the stakeholders that are
actually then using the data to come up
with some interesting action items to go
forth
understanding now what the company is
actually doing with all this data
so uh
over the course of our kind of uh short
history where there have been uh
different kind of stakeholders and that
we've seen more dominant than others um
in when it comes to privacy and privacy
regulation typically the privacy office
um which sit under the legal office
are the were the first ones to kind of
define the need and tell the
organization hey you know thou shall
comply with the gdpr ccp etc
um and that kind of uh was a top-down uh
directive
typically at the board level so the
board was was really directing this
action thing is that the privacy office
they don't really have a budget and
they're not an operational group they're
like the the knesset right they they
legislate rules for you to to uh to take
action on and so um
[Music]
the the the two main groups that were
required to really take ownership of
that solution
and and and perform those directives
were typically either coming from the
security organization those are the cso
um or from
a new type of organization that we're
seeing more and more come up which is
the chief data officer chief data
officer and is are kind of the
librarians of the data in the
organization right they need to organize
all the data to know where the data is
located so that they can make it
accessible to other groups typically the
data analytics groups um finance groups
marketing groups so they have a
very clear visibility to the data there
are standards around how the data is
defined
it's a fairly
new or market
and so uh these are kind of the
the two uh uh constituents that said
that big id um typically deals with uh
from that perspective
um and tell me a little bit about the
company itself so you're mentioning that
that it's a startup and i think it is an
important distinction because i'm coming
in from an outsider in approach i'm
saying wow 350 people i'm imagining the
all these different structures that are
that are now de-risking the company yet
here the is the co-founder and head of
product you're saying no no we're still
we're still a startup and we're still
trying out a bunch of different things
tell me a little bit about the culture
that you have at big id um
which which i guess is is an interesting
uh phenomena because we don't yet have
many israeli companies that have reached
this many employees and so it's an
interesting inflection point
look the the fundamental thing is that
big idea is uh
investing more and more and more in the
business and continuously growing
right so you're always in a struggle to
hire
people and hire the right people um it's
always about
adding more activities more products
more more
sales geographies
more sales plays it's always about
extending what you have
um and it's less about currently at
least
although we do care about efficiencies
we're more focused on the top line and
really land grab right kind of approach
of reaching as many customers as we can
um and that reflects uh
across the board on on the um
on the culture right uh
first of all you know and we our our
core kind of um
values are really about uh what we call
care do and try what it means is care
about the customer look at the customer
what does the customer want and take
care of that customer all through that
journey of sales and then deployment and
renewal
so that's a very clear focus
customer wins on every
conversation we all work for the
customer and that also uh kind of
eliminates a lot of uh internal barriers
or conversations or you know when people
are don't agree you know we ask the
customer we see what the customer needs
and that in many cases uh help us
really focus on what we need to do even
when we're doing a whole lot of things
at once
the other thing is being very action
driven doing doing first and not
over complicating it with uh
with all kinds of considerations and
concerns right really taking action even
if that if you know that this action
isn't perfect or you don't have
everything you need at once you know
that you'll have a second chance and a
third chance and a fourth chance so
doing it iteratively uh you know when it
comes to uh
to product it's releasing as as as fast
as we can
knowing that we'll have more iterations
and more chances to improve uh and if
there isn't um enough interest from the
customer then you know we may switch or
way we may do other things but
um don't be concerned about uh about
then you know not doing
trying is another aspect of it it's kind
of the other side of that coin
which means that you know we're not
afraid to try and go out and and and
challenge new markets uh even if uh if
we we might fail or everybody else
thinks that that we might fail
we started big id we entered into a
mature market right there were big
players data security was there for 10
15 years you know when we started big id
and we looked for funding
many of the security investors looked at
us and said you know who needs to know
who the data belongs to you know because
it wasn't a factor in cyber security who
who is whose social security is this or
who cares who social security is this
you need to protect it but for privacy
and for data analytics and for
getting more value out of the data you
really need to know whose data it is
so we and and we uh we said you know
we're going to do something different
we're going to offer a solution you know
10 years of dlp
failed projects that's one of the other
things that was scary initially for the
customers that it's a hard problem to
solve we said we're going to solve that
problem in a different way
um so we tried and and
and we succeeded you know in some areas
we failed in some areas we had to to uh
kind of recalculate but trying is a
really important thing and across the
organization you know we are we never
punish anyone for trying or failing
that's not the point the point is that
uh even if you fail you learn from it
and you uh change course and you're
flexible enough to change course and to
do what needs to be done and i think
those are kind of the core things that
uh
that make us uh make us special um
yeah and of course um
it's important to also enjoy the the
journey right
you can't really be very good at
something if you don't enjoy it and
that's a that's a very important aspect
as well of our company
a hundred percent nimrod thank you for
taking the time to share with me uh both
your own journey as well as uh that of
big idea and the culture inside i i have
a few last questions and i want to take
you back now to to nimrod a little bit
earlier to your childhood before a big
id before sca what what really
fascinated you well what drove your
curiosity when you were a kid
well uh you know i told you that i
started late my my journey you know i
was as a kid i was
fascinated by airplanes
and by uh and by space and and uh and so
uh i spent uh kind of that my childhood
there and i then uh you know was was
fortunate enough to to uh also uh be a
pilot for a certain period of time which
uh
very very soon i understood that it's
not my career for the long term
but at least that was really what drove
me but um
throughout my childhood i was always uh
with building things
with lego
building things with uh
with with computers at some point uh you
know uh
skateboard with sales and uh and things
like that that was really my my passion
um
and uh yeah and and later on i kind of
um i was always uh i was always good at
math so i figured you know what uh if if
i'm not going to be a pilot as a career
maybe i'll do something in computer
science and that's how i got into high
tech
amazing and and what inspires you today
on a day-by-day basis as you go about
your work and personal life
i think that um
you know the one person that
you probably hear a lot that inspires me
is elon musk right and his uh is his
kind of
limitless uh
approach and um his uh kind of ability
uh
to
um go out there and do whatever he wants
right and um
and i think that uh you know to me
that's that's inspiring limitless and
that's kind of the essence of trying i
think
uh of uh there's really nothing that you
um
you cannot do right um and um and you
just need to be focused on it you need
to get the right people to help you
build it
and and you need to be flexible and be
able to correct course and learn and uh
and and and if you do that
you know there's nothing that can stop
you
amazing
and what are three words you would use
to describe yourself
oh that's a that's a tough tough
question i actually been thinking about
it ever since you've raised it i think
look i think that the you know the the
values of the company really describe
kind of my my motto right
caring
caring doing and trying right and that
is really the core of uh
i think that describes my my um
personality i think it also describes my
co-founders my partner's personality and
that's uh that's why i kind of
got into our our core values of the
company
thank you very very much best of luck
with the rest of the journey for big
idea i know it's just the beginning and
but it sounds amazing and thank you for
taking the time to stay with me thank
you thank you
[Music]